i also love how and i relate to this
your trajectory of going from a younger
actress and then into a love story genre
because i love love and i'm a romantic
yeah and i i don't there's enough
darkness everywhere i want the antidote
i need the happy and the positive and
now you're like this rom-com
queen which i love and this new film um
the in beach first of all the kissing
booth was such a phenomenon thank you um
and then
this new film
the in between i'm drooling it's like
it reminds me of big classic film
sweeping films the ghost the vow that's
kind of the thing we were going for we
were going for like teenage modern
ghosts it's you did it yeah you did it
it's so good
thank you i really wish like i would
love to since we don't have a pottery
scene in our movie i like wish you and i
could just get in there together and
make a make a voz or something we're
going to make some google i don't know
so maybe we can get in position
um
and uh it's not pottery it's kugel um i
also i mean this film is so exciting
it's so romantic it's so fulfilling yeah
it's on paramount plus
run don't walk i don't want to get it
it's really sad but it's also really fun
and it's like you know it's really good
so if you want to watch it
but your grandmother
the parlay into finding this project
couldn't be more meaningful yeah this
project came to me and it was i fell in
love with it for various reasons but one
reason that really stuck out to me that
was just like for me
so the story is that um so my
grandfather died before i was born i'm
named after him uh joey his name was
joseph um but
my grandma my grandfather after he
passed my grandmother had these vivid um
they're called adc's after death
communications with him just like in
this film you know he he passes away and
tessa experiences these things and is
trying to reach him in the in-between so
they can keep their love alive even
though he's no longer um and so my
grandmother after my grandfather passed
had these vivid vivid dreams where she
could like feel like the hair on his
head in these dreams and she's been
telling me these stories since i was
like a very very small girl and like the
gusto that she tells these stories with
has been the same from when i was little
to now so when this project came about
it was just so meaningful to me to like
tell a story that had like this personal
tie to my grandmother who is just my i
love her so much
and my grandfather who i'm named after
it's just it felt so beautiful and
serendipitous for sure
speaking of
um is it true that when you were on the
conjuring
that you got
um like physical stuff happened to you
the conjuring is
it's a oh she's yeah
it is a fun acting challenge oh it was
amazing but yeah it was pretty and it
was pretty intense some weird stuff
happened on set along with the movie
being scary it's true i developed this
bizarre
rare out of nowhere blood disorder um
and basically my my body like all the
red platelets from my body were like
drained they were just like gone so i
had like high risk of internal bleeding
um and i was potentially gonna need like
a blood transfusion it was so dramatic
so i had to every day before work and
after work go to the hospital get my
blood taken and then
all of a sudden i got home
and i've never had a problem with my
blood since
like oh you think that's crazy yeah i
think it's crazy it's just it's every
time i think about it like i just like
shudder a little bit just oh hoo
[Music]